I was sent an invitation to perform at a
student Society night and kinda attached
to the invitation was the following
contract which they asked me to sign the
title of the document is behavioral
agreement form this comedy night
organized by the UNICEF Society aims to
provide a safe space for everyone to
come together to share and listen to
comedy this is the chance for all to be
entertained and overjoyed by the
different performances this contract has
been written to ensure an environment
with joy love and acceptance is
reciprocated by all by signing this
contract you are agreeing to our no
tolerance policy with regards to racism
sexism classism ageism ableism
homophobia biphobia transfer basing upon
Islamophobia anti religion and anti
eighties all topics must be presented in
a way that is respectful and kind
we like to dance so what I thought I'd
do searches most of you so much say here
last month I'm going to do the same set
but I'm gonna be respectful not only of
the letter of the rules but also of the
spirit of the rules to make sure that I
risk offending No
my name is Constance and Kissin thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]